foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
to gag or not to gag that is the
question this morning
will the judge
issue a gag order
or protective order
Jack Smith is seeking for Donald Trump
to shut his uh [__] mouth on fraud
social
I have a lot of opinions on this
as some may know I I expressed my deep
concern yesterday on the patreon Sunday
rant
um but I'm and I told them yesterday
last night because we normally do the
patreon ran at like 8 P.M Central that's
9 p.m Eastern on Sundays
so if you wanna if you want to join in
on those go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels you can check it out there but
I told them yesterday I said look okay
look
this whole this whole uh true social
posting threats thing everyone is not
seeing it for what it truly is it is
Donald Trump testing this judge and
seeing how far he can take her
and to see if they can have her somehow
removed for conflict of interest or some
stupid [__]
this is a this is a chaos machine
strategy this is not Donald Trump I mean
he is a lunatic
but this isn't his lunacy doing this
this is his his ego thinking that he can
talk his way out of anything that's what
this is
um and I I've expressed I've expressed
my frustration about some analysis in
the media and yeah people are pissed off
that I keep saying this out loud and
they're mad that I'm I'm speaking
against former United States prosecutors
and former lawyers or lawyers or
whatever and I really don't give a [__]
because the thing is is that I'm going
to be authentic here and I'm going to
tell you the [__] truth
that's what I'm gonna do that's what I
have been doing that's what I'll
continue to do I'm not going to fill you
up full of a bunch of false hope and
[__] and lies and misinformation
it's not going to happen not me not know
how not anywhere and you can be mad if
that's if you came here to for me to
feed you false hope
you are in the wrong place we have
cathartic release Here There is a
difference in false hope and cathartic
release
absolutely 100 complete opposites
I am not going to give you something
that I know is not true for instance and
a lot of people are gonna hate me for
this bear with me hang on put your
[__] seat belts on because I'm gonna
say it there will not be there will not
be a televised trial in DC you can yell
it you can scream it you can talk about
it but it is a rule it is rule number 53
that was passed in 1946.
okay
this judge is a damn good judge and my
guess is because she was a public
defender and she she was also a
prosecutor and now she's a federal judge
she's smart
she she she had a unanimous vote for her
confirmation in the Senate 95 to nothing
this judge is gonna follow the law
what don't you understand the judge is
gonna follow the law that's what
chuckan's gonna do
and if you don't like it that's gonna be
your disappointment and the reason why
is because you keep listening to people
who are just giving you false hope to
get you engaged and that's not what we
need to engage in going on a huge
campaign about televising a trial that
is likely to happen after the election
is not going to help us politicize
issues for this election what how how
many times do I have to say it
and I I don't care who I'm speaking
against I don't give a [__] because what
this is and I again I know Tony you're
you're attacking the left I'm not
attacking the left what I'm doing is
trying to pluck your head out of your
ass to realize what is at risk what is
at stake it is our democracy this is not
a reality TV show
that is not what this is and there are
not and and by the way let me repeat it
one more time if I don't a thousand
rule 53 that was instituted in 1946 are
you listening people out there who don't
understand what the judge is going to do
she's going to follow the rules and the
law that's what she's going to do and
that's what all judges federal judges
are going to do they're not going to go
outside the bounds of the law here I
mean besides Canon maybe but Canon is
not going to make a decision about
cameras in the courtroom in DC
rule 50 go Google it if you have to rule
53 Institute in 1946 and you know I
don't normally bring the data and the
facts to Bear here but this this is a
particular instance where I must say
something
this judge is not going to allow cameras
in the courtroom and there's not a judge
out there that is going to change this
not for him and besides we don't want
this to be a reality TV show
this is our democracy at stake
if you want cameras in the courtrooms
there's plenty of opportunities fonnie
Willis is more likely to indict him this
week in Georgia guess what is allowed in
Georgia courtrooms sometimes cameras
broadcasting so if you want if you want
to televise a trial the Georgia one is
probably the one to televise and and to
be completely honest if there's a if
there's a chance if there's even a
chance in hell for for a trial
before this election it's in Georgia
it's in Fulton County Georgia that is
where a trial could happen more than
likely depending on how many defendants
they are and how quickly Bonnie Willis
can move and get a judge to set a date
now as far as his [__] his [__]
testing the judge over the weekend
he's that's all he's doing is testing
the judge to see how far he can take
this
because he's he's getting his his
supporters his sheep froth up into a
Mania
to where they'll storm DC again that's
what he wants
he wants another January 6th that's what
he wants
he wants the country to believe that we
have to put him in power or we're all in
danger that's the lunacy again he's a
[__] Maniac he's a buffoon
but he operates in a chaos machine
and he has one of the most loudest
spectacular chaos machines out there
it's absolutely infuriating
how he's shifted
moods in our country
but it's true but again everyone getting
their hopes up on social media this
weekend that this judge is somehow gonna
put him in jail you are dumb as dog [__]
yes do I want him in jail of course I do
do would I love to have the perp walk
absolutely would I love to have cameras
in the courtroom to watch that sad sack
of [__] get his ass handed to him by
Jack Smith and Jack Smith prosecutors of
course I would
but there's more important [__] at stake
way more important stuff that we could
be doing there's way way better
campaigns and way better energy that we
could place to make Ron DeSantis Chris
Christie and Donald Trump and Mike Pence
eat each other
that is where our aim should be
destroying the Republican party not
Trump you think this Republican party
isn't going to live past Trump I showed
you the evidence last week of Rush
Limbaugh explaining that this was a cult
before Trump
the Republican party has been a cult for
years disguised as their fascism
disguises conservatism and then the Tea
Party they they always were a cult they
never had their desperate cult leader
never did they have their desperate cult
leader
and that's what he is he's their
desperate cult leader that's why they
will not leave him that's why they will
[__] nominate him is because they're
a cult they've been a cult for decades
they just never had a leader
that's what this is
and to act like it's anything different
is absolutely
something way out in left field
and to pretend that if if this judge
doesn't put him in jail then it's the
worst thing that our democracy can have
no the worst thing that our democracy
can do is not pay attention to what is
at stake
you you are our government you are our
democracy you are what stands in the way
of trumpism and fascism taking control
in this country he keeps saying well uh
they're coming after you but I'm in
their way
they're coming after your democracy and
you are the one standing in their way
it's always projection with him
understand this
and this morning you're going to be
disappointed because I have a feeling
this judge
is gonna say well you just need to be
careful Mr Mr Trump you just and and
cheat rightfully so really these
messages Mike Pence look listen Mike
Pence is running for president folks and
he's a witness in this case
Mike Pence has put our country in in a
very tough position if anything any
everyone should be calling for Mike
Pence to drop out of the race so that he
can be a witness instead of a candidate
because he can't be both
he cannot be both
and we may not get Mike Pence to drop
out until Iowa that's six months away
so understand what's at stake understand
why these things are happening
and to Take Your Eye Off the ball and
act like a televised trial that may not
happen until after the election is
absolutely the worst kind of waste of
energy that we could be having and yes
I'm saying it no one likes it I get it I
get it only a few of you out there are
[__] probably agreeing with me I'm
not reading the comments right now
I'm trying to make sure that my your
comments are not swaying my commentary
I will not be changed on my mind on this
this judge is gonna follow the law she's
gonna follow the rules that is what this
judge does
when she needs to be tough she's tough
so let her do her job
let Jack Smith do his job we should be
doing our job
our job and that is the work of the
ballot
that is what we should be doing we
should be engaging in our democracy that
way
we should politicize the ever loving
[__] out of every single moment but
there isn't a moment to televise a trial
that's not a thing
you're trying to create a moment that
doesn't exist
use and politicize the moments that do
this week is going to be a hell of a
week to politicize
everything that Donald Trump has crimed
on that's right
there's gonna be PL I mean this morning
judge Cannon issuing this this this
statement this morning basically
basically Paving the way for Donald
Trump to try to dismiss this case the
11th circuit couldn't be closer
and again
you noticed he's not attacking judge
Cannon
you notice that
you notice he's he stopped attacking the
Manhattan D.A the reason why is because
judge Cannon is on his side and the
reason why he stopped
harassing on true social the Manhattan
D.A is because he knows they'll come to
rest his ass and he's testing this judge
in DC to see how far he can take her
and to see how how angry he can make his
supporters what he can get them to
stochastically to do
so be vigilant use your [__] brain
cells and yes I understand I understand
there's a lot of my allies and people I
get along with online and all that [__]
that are saying what they're saying
about the trial being televised but I'm
telling you don't don't buy into it
don't buy it
don't buy it pay attention to something
else there is more to engage in I beg of
you
we can't this listen to me
do you remember in 2016
do you remember in 2016 when the Access
Hollywood tape dropped
you remember that
do you remember that moment
almost everyone who hated Trump was like
yes this is the end this is it this is
the thing that will take him out
foreign
where he is testing this judge another
Access Hollywood moment
I believe it is I believe he's securing
the nomination this week
he's Gathering up his supporters he's
Gathering up his support
he's he's getting them ready it'll be
wild type [__]
he's securing this nomination
because these people are the worst
versions of themselves he's given them
permission
yes it's sad that a certain percentage
of the American population is lost
in delusion lost in hate lost in anger
now I've been watching the videotape of
the the Montgomery brawl down in Alabama
on the boat dock where the ferry the
ferry dock
and a lot of people are cheering it a
lot of people are saying it's sad a lot
a lot a lot a lot of Maga is really
upset that a bunch of white dudes
got their [__] asses kicked because
they wouldn't move their goddamn boat
because they think their privilege is
way more important
than what any black man especially a
black security guard is going to tell
him so much so that they jump him and
fight him and beat his ass well they
[__] around and found out didn't they
down in Montgomery Alabama
but there's a certain portion of our
population
that is going to hang with Trump
they're not going to leave him they're
not going to back away no matter what we
do no matter what the judge does no
matter what the trials say no matter
what the convictions are no matter what
the jail time is
they'll support him and be with him long
after he crops
because he allowed them to be who they
wanted to be the worst version of
themselves
take my word for it
go look at the evidence I show it to you
all day every day two hours
and what to do about it what to do about
it don't don't act like something that
should exist is existing and it's true
it's not true go look it up I don't give
a [__] who tells you that this is gonna
happen go look up rule 53. that was that
was put in place in 1946
they're not going to change it for him
and they shouldn't we should not give
him any kind of special treatment or the
privilege of a reality TV show in his
trial where he tried to overturn our
government try him convict him and jail
him like we do every other [__]
criminal in those federal courts
do it
what could be so hard about that
Focus your energy on what the Democracy
needs not what it wants
it's so important that we don't lose
sight of that
that we don't get distracted by some
kind of shiny object that it's not gonna
manifest or likely to never happen
again
if you want a trial
your best opportunity is in the state of
New York and the state of Georgia those
states allow cameras in their courtrooms
if you want to focus your your energy on
a campaign to televise a trial why don't
you go where one can be televised
stop listening to the misinformation and
yes you may say Tony you're accusing a
lot of people that you know
I am
and they should be ashamed and they
should stop as well
this judge is going to follow the law is
going to follow the rules I I am very
confident in that
I think you're going to see that this
afternoon I think I think a lot of
people on Twitter and social media are
going to be super pissed off that this
judge doesn't do what you want her to do
because that is not the normal course of
action the normal course of action is to
give him some kind of gag and he's gonna
break it
she's gonna warn him and he's gonna push
her to see how far he can
that's what the stupid [__] motion of
change of venue in West Virginia is
about
that's what it's about they know it's
not going to change they know that it's
a delay tactic and more than anything
it's a fundraising tactic and it's the
chaos machine tactic
get it through your thick heads this is
what he does know him you know him
you've seen him we've had to deal with
this piece of sludge for the last seven
years
Don't Take Your Eye Off what is
important
and what is important here is to
politicize these issues to draw wedges
between these Republican candidates to
let them destroy each other
and let Trump destroy himself he will be
the nominee
it's it's all but guaranteed other than
maybe him choking on a Big Mac and
leaving this Earth before he hits the
ground
God that I don't believe in willing
so be mad at me be pissed off go take to
social media and and have an uprising
against me good go talk about it go talk
about what I'm saying
I made the mistake in 2016 of believing
that no matter what Trump won't win
there's no way Trump could win
and boy after the Access Hollywood tape
oh man I was just sure as [__] of it
we didn't fully understand how to beat
Trump in 2016.
we evaluated we moved towards more
pro-democracy Coalition activities and
we beat him in the midterms we beat him
in 2020 and we beat the Republicans
again in 2022.
and we will win again in 2024 if we stay
focused
if we stay engaged if we point our
strategic outrage towards the
appropriate politicization to win this
election with the ballot
it is most important
more important now than ever and I told
you time and time again in 2022 it was
the most important election of our
democracy's lifetime
and now again here we are in this moment
this 2024 election with the Republican
primary cycle already started even as
early as it is that was his intention
this is the most important election of
our democracy's lifetime and we must we
must stay engaged and we must stay
focused of what is most important to our
country now right in this moment
and it is not wasting our energy and
time yelling and screaming about
something that is probably not going to
happen
it is ridiculous
again a waste of energy and a waste of
oxygen and not something that we should
be engaging in we should be engaging in
things that will win us the election
not win us a great ticket to a reality
show after the election more than likely
so pluck your head out of your ass
and understand what's at stake
and understand that we need to get it
together here
we cannot we cannot lose our focus on
the Access Hollywood tape we cannot lose
our Focus because we know that this one
thing will make him lose even if she
jails him he will win
the primary are you not understanding
he's he's almost daring her to jail him
so that he'll guarantee the primary
he's a cult leader they're a cult
I'm not saying she shouldn't
frankly having having Trump arrested is
a good thing think about this for wrap
your mind around this for a minute
Donald Trump is likely to have the
headline Trump arrested again maybe
maybe a half dozen more times it's
possible
there there is a good chance he's going
to be indicted and arrested in Georgia
next week there could be another chance
in Michigan and Arizona with the state
elector schemes there
and his call to the governor while the
governor was certifying the [__]
electors do you remember that
he called the governor of Arizona while
he was certifying the electors
folks
there are more important things in
cameras in a courtroom
and if she jails him good
good if she jails him if she doesn't
jail him and he keeps going and then she
jails him good
good
but we must operate in a in a realm of
reality
we cannot get outside of what reality
truly is and understanding what is in
front of us and what is in front of us
is a is a fever pitch cult
and he is going to bring them to the
highest temperature he possibly can
Tony are you saying we should be scared
no we should be vigilant of what is
important
and we should fight on that Battlefield
we should fight on that Battlefield not
a battlefield of hopes and dreams [__]
hopes and dreams [__] [__] go and be
going High when they go low [__] that
[__]
[__] that [__]
it's time to fight where we fight and we
fight for our democracy at the ballot
and we fight for our democracy on the
ballot
like in Ohio Kerry lake is in Ohio
Republicans are trying to move the
[__] goal post by changing polling
stations and polling locations if you're
in Ohio pay the [__] attention
pay attention to what they're doing it's
Republican control and they're tampering
with polling locations at the very last
moment
the day before the election
Christopher Webb has it on on Twitter
I'm gonna show it to you
now is the time to stay vigilant now is
the time to stay focused [__] those
goddamn cameras in a goddamn courtroom
that on a trial that isn't even close to
happening it's not even scheduled yet
and you're bitching about cameras
pluck your head out of your [__] ass
it's time to fight for your democracy
and it's time to fight where the battle
is fought and it's at the ballot
not no goddamn Federal courtroom
understand this
be mad at me if you must be frustrated
at me at me if you must because I'm not
saying the thing you want me to say
but it's not the thing that should be
said and that's the point
that's the point
feeling good about something
that will never happen
is not worth a good God damn
it's not worth a good goddamn
feeling good about the Access Hollywood
would tape where he talked about
sexually assaulting women because he
could because he's famous
and feeling good about it that that was
the end and he was gonna have to drop
out and all the Republicans were abandon
him they all voted for him they all
supported him in the end
the Republican party has always
been a [__] cult
and it will be for a long time
they just now got their [__] cult
leader and if you expect me if you
expect me to use this microphone to feed
you a bunch of [__] so you feel good
instead of giving you the tools that you
need to go out and save our [__]
Nation
then you're out of your mind because
that ain't what I'm gonna do here every
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central if you
love me you love me if you love to hate
me ooh baby even better hit that
subscribe button right now if you love
me or love to hate me and hit the
[__] like button down below or you
can hit that dislike button if you don't
like what I'm saying today go ahead
engage get in the chat tell me why I'm
wrong
do it let's go let's [__] go and
let's do this thing of democracy and
let's do it together
let's do it together that is what the
intention is that is how we save this
country from trumpism from American
fascism from manga from the real America
First Nazis don't go anywhere I'm gonna
be right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show are you mad at
me yet
are you upset are you mad
that I don't have this name Outlook as
every other person
[Music]
I want him in jail
I want him in jail how the [__] could I
want him in jail of course I want him in
jail but it's a reality thing like she's
not just going to slap him in jail and
if she does I'll cheer it on
you know that I just I just think I just
think the distraction of all the
nonsense and the wasted energy on a
campaign of something that will not
happen because you gotta understand that
this judge is not going to go outside
the boundaries of her rules or the law
it's it's ridiculous to think that she's
going to do that
or ask to do that it's ridiculous it's
absolutely [__] ridiculous to even
suggest that this judge who is probably
one of the best judges on the January 6
case if you look at this not one case
not one case has been given a different
video venue on January 6 because it
happened in Washington
in Washington
right
that's why he's being tried there for
this case
it's the reason why Canon this morning
is trying to make the argument why are
you convening a grand jury in DC and not
in the jurisdiction where you're trying
to try this case
that's what Canon's basically saying
this morning and Canon's signaling to
Trump on a dismissal for on those
grounds you understand that right
uh someone and again I want to be clear
here because uh hedge enemy I think
you're you are you're a regular here and
I disagree You can disagree with me this
is healthy
I disagree I think there's a compelling
public interest in televising this case
the law should be repealed yes
agreed but that's not reality right the
law should be repealed by who by what
what do you think how do you think this
is going to happen just because there's
a social media campaign
I mean the social media campaigns wanted
Trump tried and convicted of seditious
conspiracy he's not charged with that
so again again you wanted you wanted a
judge in the south Florida documents
case to not be so [__] biased against
Trump but that's not how it works
and she's not going to recuse herself
she's not she's proven it already and
there's probably no way to get where to
Canon even though people told you out
there that oh she's gonna she's not
gonna be the judge yes she is
listen I understand what you want I know
what you want
I want it too but I'm not gonna say it
just because I want it as if it's going
to happen
it's it's a [__] it's a [__]
thing to do
to [__] feed you for a bunch of false
hope
when I know it not to be true
I know it not to be true
it's just not
so hedge I I'm so glad you're here and
I'm so glad that you're posting in the
comments that you disagree with me and I
want you to continue to come here and
tell me why I'm wrong
this is how we actually do democracy
this right here
engaging one-on-one
live
so I appreciate and respect your opinion
I agree I think that law should be
repealed I think there is no real good
reason that federal judges have to keep
cameras out of courtrooms criminal
courtrooms and on a federal level
but it it does
just because I want it doesn't mean that
the fact
doesn't remain
this is the difference between belief
and opinion
my belief is that it should be repealed
and that we should have transparency in
these Federal courtrooms I actually
think these trials that actually do
reach the federal system and the
criminal justice system on the federal
level would be more transparent and we
would get more action against the
federal government using their Long
Hammer their heavy Hammer to lock people
away for long periods of time
for non-violent crimes a lot of times
but there's also my opinion my belief
and my opinion are two separate things
yes I'm good at compartmentalizing them
I guess
my beliefs are not based in fact
sometimes they're based in the way I
feel
and the way I want things to be my
opinion has to be based on a certain set
of facts
and the facts remain cameras are not
allowed in a federal criminal trial and
this judge is not going to go outside
those bounds I just don't believe it
those are the facts she's never shown to
go outside the bounds of the rules and
the law of the courtroom
why would she now and why would any
other federal judge at this point
and yes should it be repealed absolutely
the law should be repealed but why focus
on it now why now
why not use this as as as the example of
why it should be and we'll do it when
the trial happens now is the time for
the election now is the time to save our
democracy now is the time to win and we
can win without a camera in that
courtroom I guaran God damn tiit if we
do it correctly
if we do it correctly we will beat him
again bigly
we will beat him again bigly
and that is what our country really
needs our country does not need a trial
our country does not need Donald Trump
to go to prison what our country needs
is a message
a message to show
this these [__] just like they were
shown on that dock in Montgomery Alabama
when that fairy couldn't Dock and that
security guard time and time again asked
those [__] people to move their boat
and then they jumped him like they had
some sort of privilege to park there and
jump him and they [__] around and
found out
we can save our democracy folks
we can do it we just have to stay
focused
we have to
and getting off track about some camera
in a courtroom that probably isn't even
going to happen after the election
is not the focus we need
he can still win if we don't fight on
the battlefield where it needs to be
fought hedge I'm so glad you're here I
hope you keep with the comments keep
them coming
keep them coming
because I I don't I don't think I'm
gonna back down from this to be quite
honest with you
I don't think I'm gonna I don't think
I'm gonna back down from this
[Laughter]
at the joy leave say show it wanna see
you want to see the trial I understand I
get it I I know what you're saying
again I'm not saying I don't want to see
the trial but I I'm just saying the
energy wasted
the energy wasted could be could be put
together so much better to draw a wedge
let me show you let me show you a clip
of Rhonda Santos here now let's see if I
can find it this morning and um Rhonda
Santos you know he is a weak he is a
weak little [__] oh my God he's so weak
but here's here's him on how Trump lost
right
this this is the important Battle of the
fight you want to see the battle of the
fight here's here's where your energy
can go into this wedge if you want if
you want energy into a wedge let me see
if I can get my volume correct it's been
over the weekends I just want to make
sure I got it all going here okay
here is Rhonda Santos on rather Trump
won or lost listen yes or no did Donald
Trump lose the 2020 election whoever
puts their hand on the Bible on January
20th every four years uh is the winner
okay but first
what a weak piece of [__] what a weak
piece of [__]
this is the number two
and the guy's like well um I can't say
that Trump lost because because his
supporters will be really mad at me Oh
They'll be really mad at me and Trump
will say something awful about me which
is exactly what we want
it's exactly what we want we want Ron
DeSantis and Trump to fight that's what
we want
it is going to help us in the general
trust me on this it will help in the
general if we get them to battle each
other and get these idiots to admit that
yes he [__] lost
let's let's continue see if she
pressures him what she does here I'll
give you a hint she pressures him but
let's see what he says respectfully you
did not clearly answer that question and
if you can't give a yes or no on whether
or not Trump lost then how of course no
of course he lost
oh
of course of course he lost he doesn't
want to say it but he know he has to say
it listen I've been telling Rhonda
santis since like February March I
believe Ron drop at get stop being
Governor resign as Governor get in the
fight and just start pounding him but he
wouldn't do it he wouldn't do it and the
reason why is because he's terrified of
the Trump supporters not supporting him
this [__] ass [__] Ron DeSantis
meatball pudding fingers can't can't get
his his
weak ass wokeness [__] out of his brain
to understand how he could be the
nominee and I knew he wouldn't I knew he
wouldn't
you know that I said there's no [__]
chance in the hell that Ron can win
he doesn't understand he thinks he think
listen to me you want to know what Ron
DeSantis thinks
are you bearing with me because you
might have to put your seat belt on
after what I said about the the cameras
in the courtroom Rhonda santus
is relying on the Department of Justice
and Jack Smith and and the Fulton County
D.A and the Manhattan D.A to take Trump
out
he is relying on them to take his weak
ass his weak feeble ass Rhonda santis
and these other [__] candidates
are betting and hoping that the
Department of Justice and Jack Smith and
the prosecutors will save their
campaigns
and they're not going to that it's not
their job Rhonda santis is drowning in
weirdness because he is relying on
someone else to do the job for him
just like we the people cannot rely on
Jack Smith and the Department of Justice
and other prosecutors to save our
democracy
that's what weakness looks like
that's what it looks like
have some strength Ron
know that they're not going to save your
campaign by getting rid of trump he's
not going anywhere
get some [__] courage grow you a
[__] spine and fight Ron fight
like your [__] political career
depends on it let's hear
I've lost the 2020 election of course
Joe Biden is the president but the issue
is I think what what people in the media
and elsewhere they want to act like
somehow
of course
is the president
so what are we going to do are we going
to act like Ron is that what we're gonna
do we're gonna act like Ron
and hope hope that they jail him and
hope that he it causes him to drop out
and people to stop supporting him when
he's indicted and convicted and goes to
trial get the [__] out of here with that
[__] I am not gonna stand back and be a
weak [__] ass [__] like Ron DeSantis
that is not what I'm gonna do that's not
what I think the [__] band's gonna do
I don't think that's what the sparklers
how spark sparklers come here and watch
this show the Midas Mighty comes here
and watch this show I don't think that's
what they're gonna do they're not gonna
stand back and let the Department of
Justice and Jack Smith save their
democracy [__] that [__] they're gonna
fight and we need to fight it on the
battleground of the ballot and it's
perfectly right here in this moment
where Ron DeSantis is doing the old
bobblehead
that's where we fight
that's the race that's the race at our
hand right now in front of us the race
that is going on right now is the
Republican primary
Ron DeSantis is number two three maybe
if you count for Vic the Trump plant
and then Trump is the presumptive
nominee
so what are you gonna do
are you going to be weak and feeble like
this fool are you gonna fight huh You're
Gonna You're Gonna Stand Back
and and let the department adjust hope
they save you hook Jack Smith saves your
democracy when it's not his job it's not
finally will it's his job to save our
democracy it's funny Wilson's job
prosecute crimes in Fulton County
Georgia which she's gonna do
because she ain't no weak ass
[__] either
funny Willis is a [__] fighter she
don't give two [__]
and I actually believe there's more of a
chance that he'll be jailed in Fulton
County than anywhere in this country
the sheriff has already said released a
memo hey I don't give a [__] who he is
he will be fingerprinted he will be mug
shot he will be treated like every other
lowly son of a [__] that comes in here
that's indicted on on felony charges and
it's only sending a signal that the
sheriff knows that Donald Trump is going
to be [__] indicted on felony charges
in Fulton County Georgia
to be honest I would much rather Donald
Trump be jailed in Fulton County Georgia
than [__] DC Hells to the yeah Hells
to the yeah bring some [__] Heat
that's the [__] trial that is most
likely to happen before the election if
any of them happened the Manhattan D.A
is all but [__] pause their their
[__] all but paused it if you haven't
noticed
judge cannons run running running
[__] game for Donald Trump down in
South Florida if you really think that
son of a [__] is going to trial before
the election you're out of your [__]
mind you haven't been reading or
watching her statements
and the way this and the way that that
he's acting in the January 6 case in DC
we're talking about we're talking about
delays delays delays
so the one place that there is a
potential for cameras jail time
for Trump until trial and a trial it's
Fulton County Georgia baby
that's the one I'm excited about
Linda on YouTube says hell no we fight I
know you I know you guys got fight in
you hell why would you come here and
listen to my ass every day if you didn't
have fight in you
of course you've got fight I'm just I'm
just trying to show you where the fight
really truly is that's all I'm trying to
do
and I'm trying to give you the tools too
we're doing this really cool thing on
patreon I don't know if you guys have
seen it or heard about it or heard
people talking about it in the chat but
it's Roundtable for democracy it's
completely different than the show
completely different and the reason why
I'm doing it on patreon is I'm I'm just
doing it in small groups because we're
doing workshops
I'm releasing every single video to the
public if you want you can watch the
playlist of all the videos we've done so
far we're supposed to do another
Workshop this week
with Jess Piper I think tomorrow I'm
going to do a workshop on Mom's demand
action website we're just going to look
at the website together we're going to
try to figure out how we can use this
website and why it's important and I'm
hoping I can maybe get Shannon Watts to
come and do a workshop and teach us
specifically about engaging on gun
violence
Mom's demand action is such a great
resource we should know how to use it
and I want to do workshops to figure out
how to use that resource and all the
resources last week we had the mighty
librarian our local librarian here at
the [__] fam she has a resource for
state election laws you can go see it
now on the playlist just go to Round
Table of democracy.com that's Roundtable
of democracy.com right now that takes
you straight to the playlist
or you can or you can just subscribe to
the YouTube channel right here and just
go over to the the playlist tab there's
a round table of democracy one on there
we have a video about fivecalls.org we
have the resource that Mighty librarian
has put together for you to find all the
election laws right at your fingertips
write it a click of a button it's so
easy it's such a great resource that she
put together and we're going to continue
these workshops to show you how to
engage I'm not just going to tell you to
engage this this next 16 18 months we're
going to show you how to engage
that's what we want and I'm going to
host those workshops on patreon so if
you want to participate in them live go
to patreon.com but don't worry if you
can't join patreon it's okay I'm gonna
make them all available to the public
you'll be able to watch every single one
of them absolutely free I'm not gonna
hold them or gate them for you to see
them you're gonna get to watch these
workshops it's just easier to manage
when we're in a smaller group
so so go to Roundtable of democracy.com
catch up on those videos I know you're I
know over the next year you're gonna
find one of these workshops that you're
gonna go hey I can do that that's how I
can engage I like that idea we're gonna
do a texting a texting one too
um uh maybe we'll do that one this week
too so maybe we might have three
workshops this week we need to get on
this fast
uh field team six everyone's been
talking about field team six I want to
do a training uh workshop on that where
we just go through the website so you
get comfortable of what it is and it's
about texting we did one on
fivecalls.org where you call
where you call your representative we
want to do one on how do you text your
representative and field team six
apparently has great resources right at
our fingertips we just need to find them
and if everyone everyone can join us and
everyone can join in on engaging in the
way that they are best engaging
then we can save our democracy we do not
have to rely on the Department of
Justice or Jack Smith like [__]
meatball is here like meatballs
I want Jack Smith to put him in jail
that way I I get to run for president
I want Jack Smith to put him in jail so
Joe Biden can win no we get to let Joe
Biden win we are his votes
we are the ones who get Democrats to win
we are the ones who will make Hakeem
Jeffries the speaker of the house not
Jack Smith Jack Smith is only one vote
[__] only one vote
only one vote in our democracy we are we
are many
we are many
and we will make Biden president again
we will make a king Jeffrey's the
speaker of the house we will advance and
get more seats in the United States
Senate we will win Governor's races we
will win County commissions we will win
state representatives State Senate races
we will win School Board seats it is
time for us to do this
no matter what no backing down from the
fight the real fight
we should engage and use our energy
where it matters most and that's what
the round tables of democracy are so if
you if you want to participate why go to
patreon.com the Tony Michaels we're
going to do several of them this week it
sounds like
and then
and then if you you can't join patreon
it's okay we will make these available
to the public all the workshops are
going to be free you're not going to
have to pay a single nickel to watch
them and they're going to be they're
going to get better and better as we get
better at this the workshops will get
better and we'll redo the workshops if
we have to
so that you have them at your fingertips
to give to yourself or to other people
to find the way that you want to engage
the way that your talents because our
audience oh my God you guys are so
talented and all of it you guys are
[__] talented
the amount of talent in this audience
will save our democracy alone I truly
believe that that's why I'm doing the
Roundtable democracy woohoo did you know
that we have um
um Gabe Sanchez
he's going to be joining us today that's
right
he's going to be joining us today
he's back guess who's back guess who's
back guess who's back Gabe Sanchez is
going to be joining us at the top of the
hour
oh let's see do I have any other um a
lot of people saying they're not they're
not sure what uh is what went on in the
um
um the Montgomery Alabama brawl I might
play some of that video
I might play some of that video uh today
but you know what let me play another
video of another candidate before we go
to the break and we have Gabe Sanchez on
at the top of the hour this is another
this is another guy now he's not quite
as much of a coward
as Rhonda Santos the problem is is Chris
Christie is running to be the nominee in
2028. that's what I think I really truly
believe what we're gonna see is Chris
Christie position himself to be the
nominee or or to run to be the nominee
in 2028. that's what he's doing he's
he's he's laying the groundwork to give
back the anti-trump feeling to the
Republican Party
right he's he the Old Guard the whole
I'm a conservative you know thin failure
fascism with this cloak of conservatism
but here is here is uh Chris Christie in
this new Sunday morning shoot let's
let's listen a big test for Christy
we'll come this month at the first
Republican primary debate in Milwaukee
are you ready oh Bob I was born ready
babe what are you going to say to Trump
face to face depends on what he says I
can guarantee you I'm going to tell them
the truth for 90 minutes you know I I I
have to tell you I am really uh
if you still are not figuring out why
Trump is going to be the nominee this
example
of this is is [__] perfect because
Chris Christie really is
um the the epitome of a New Jersey tough
guy right he's always had this attitude
he's always been pretty authentic about
it right Trump is a fake tough guy he's
not really a tough guy he's a [__]
[__] but he just pretends to be a tough
guy he's a whiny little [__] now
Christy whines a lot but Chris Christie
is more authentic in his tough guidance
I guess you would say
so the idea is that the Republican Party
are a bunch of tough guys you know
they're man the man they're masculine
the image of masculinity or whatever the
[__] they think you know the Macho Man
oh yeah some [__] like that
you would think that Chris Christie
would boy sailing in the polls but he's
not and the reason why is because it's
cold and Chris Christie is out of the
cult he's not in the cult and he's
trying to run to be the cult leader it's
really weird stuff Chris it's a really
weird stuff but keep going
because the truth matters and I think
Republican voters need to hear the truth
do you think he actually shows up for
the debate oh I do yeah he keeps I think
you're full of [__] Chris
now I I'll give Chris Christie credit
here okay I'll give Chris Christie
credit
he he is doing a good job he is doing a
good job at getting uh Trump in a
position where uh he'll be able to shame
him into coming to the debate I know
what Chris Christie's doing in here he's
trying to call what I mean he literally
calls him yellow here in a second in
this interview
um but he's trying to call him yella you
remember back to the future
when um what are you yellow what are you
chicken nobody calls me chicken and then
Marty McFly Acts
on that right that's what Chris
Christie's trying to do
that's what he's trying to do because he
knows he knows that Trump is a small
weak feeble man and he knows that Trump
has to play the tough guy Macho Man
Reign here he has to play to that group
of people you know the small try that in
a small town you know the same
[__] that got their asses
kicked on a dock down in Montgomery
Alabama try that [__] in a small town
try beating the [__] out of a black
security guard in a small town because
you're a bunch of [__] racists with a
bunch of black people around oh yeah try
that in a small town that'd be real
smart but trying in the small town
people [__] around and found that down
in Montgomery Alabama I might show you
the video here's the thing
Chris Christie knows who Trump is and he
knows how to feed him in but I I
actually believe that Donald Trump is
more scared of what would happen at the
debate than he is scared of Chris
Christie calling him uh yellow but let's
listen he's suggesting he won't yeah he
loves the tease Bob finish this sentence
for me if Trump doesn't show up he is a
coward see come on what are you chicken
you see what I mean yeah what are you
chicken
and um there you go go ahead Chris
complete and total coward a yellow
streak so far down there yeah you might
think he's elevating the rest of the
field by showing up he is elevating the
rest of the field and here's the real
danger that Donald Trump has if he goes
to the debate Chris Christie will
absolutely [__] hand him his ass
he'll hand him his ass he'll show the
truth right in front of millions of
people because millions of trump voters
will watch this [__] and watch him get
[__] embarrassed by Chris Christie
Miranda santis is not going to embarrass
Trump Rhonda Santos is going to do the
same thing or Trump is going to do the
same thing that Ron DeSantis to Ronda
Santos that Trump did to Jeb Bush do you
remember that Trump destroyed Jeb Bush
in that one debate absolutely destroyed
his chances of winning I think a week
later that's when Jeb Bush is on stage
and he's like please clap please and I
don't know if you notice but Rhonda
santis can't even Rhonda Sanchez can't
even gather up a [__] crowd in Iowa
in rural Iowa
he the only chat the all listen to me
the only chance Rhonda Santa's hands is
winning Iowa that's it period if Rhonda
santis loses in Iowa or loses the Iowa
straw poll he's [__] done done done
d-o-n-e done
and he's done politically forever just
go ask Scott Walker
Squad Scott Walker but Chris Christie
understands this but Chris he's just
trying to Goat him into doing this but
let's let's listen to what Chris has to
say if
if he thinks he's elevating let's let's
back up just a bit going up she's
elevating I've never seen Donald Trump
Elevate anything except for the ego
Factor
Chris Christie is really good at this I
I'm not I'm not gonna lie and I think a
lot of you out there actually donated to
Chris Christie's campaign just to get
him on
just to get him on the debate stage
because these cowards are cowards and
they're cowards through and through I
mean here's here's Mike Pence acting
like he's a tough guy he's trying to
appeal to the tough guy think imagine
that Mike Pence trying to appeal to the
tough guy routine let's let's listen
president Trump was wrong uh he was
wrong then he's wrong now I had no right
to overturn uh the election and uh uh
more and more Americans are coming up to
me every day and recognizing that and
and uh for my part I'm running for
president in part because of
frankly president Trump asked me to put
him over the Constitution that day but I
chose the Constitution and uh I always
will
Mike Pence is admitting that Donald
Trump is guilty of the crimes that Jack
Smith and the and the D.C prosecutors
and the grand jury have
only now is Mike Pence strong enough to
say yeah [__] tried to get me to
overturn the election
so what he's literally saying
only now
now that Mike Pence's balls are in a
ringer and he's going to have to testify
Mike listen I know I know you you think
that you have a chance you do not have a
shot snowball chance in hell
at this presidential election you're not
gonna even you're not even gonna get one
delegate probably not even one vote out
of the Iowa caucus okay what you need to
do is [__] drop out of the race and
be a witness against Trump full stop do
interviews be a witness against Trump
that's what you need to do stop acting
like you're going to be [__]
president stop it
it's enough of the [__]
and do what your duty should have done
weeks prior to January 6 where you
should have been releasing public memos
saying that the president United States
is asking you to subvert the
Constitution for him and you won't do it
that's what you should have said then
then in the moment you should have had
the courage to say [__] you I do not get
to choose the Constitution over I do not
get to choose you over the Constitution
Mark milley did it
mark milley That's why [__] Trump
hates Millie is because Millie came out
in December do you remember this
he did it twice I believe maybe three
times but I remember twice in front of a
microphone Mark milley came out and said
and said out loud to the active the
inactive and veterans
you took an oath to the Constitution a
document not to a man
act accordingly
Mark milley said it in real time
real time
Mike Pence you're a little late to the
game [__] just like Liz Cheney was late
to the game I chastised her all the time
yes did she help the January 6th select
committee sure absolutely she did she
did what any [__] person who is
giving an Ode to the Constitution should
have done her and Adam kinzinger it
shouldn't be a [__] hero move to to
obey the Constitution and to live to
your oath it shouldn't be a hero move
not really
but Liz Cheney waited waited waited
almost six months before she went to the
floor of the house to say that Donald
Trump had lost that's right
it took her 190 days from the election
for Liz Cheney to go to the house floor
and say Donald Trump had lost that's not
that's not [__] strength that's
cowardice in December she was still
pushing the big lie
she was pushing the big lie
Republicans are cowards and their
cowards because they're in a cult
it is it is their tenement it has been
for years
everyone's asking where Gabe Sanchez is
at I have I really don't know I have no
idea
if uh Gabe Sanchez is uh gonna join us
or not well let's see what what the hell
is that a tiny hand uh oh it looks like
it looks like the Cheeto chop may be in
full force today folks Gabe Sanchez
welcome back to the show
how was your um how was your reprieve
there it was good it was good yeah yeah
did you uh did you get high did you get
drunk
I did all the things I did all I did I
may or may not have done all those
things I may or may not have partaken in
the the festive treats okay of the of
the
the good Lord you know what right the
the things that the good Lord gives you
is that what you're saying is that what
you're saying get more natural yeah
right were you were you following the uh
Tick Tock of trump intimidating
Witnesses over the weekend or what
people are saying is intimidating
Witnesses yeah I had I had some
reception where I was so I would
periodically check in uh I saw him go
after Nancy Pelosi as I'm go after uh
Jack Smith I saw him go after uh the the
latest judge that's been appointed
um and now and now we're waiting you
know but 2 p.m 2 p.m Pacific 5 p.m
Eastern yeah deadline for him to explain
right I mean it was well well to give
the excuse because you know that's what
he's gonna do is give and he's already
gave him the excuse online like he's
already right this is unfair yeah I
wasn't talking about them I was talking
about them I wasn't threatening I wasn't
Witnesses I wasn't I was threatening
rhinos to kill them I wasn't threatening
to kill Witnesses yeah oh great come on
great defense there buddy but what if I
were to say the Rhinos were the
witnesses well that is true all rhinos
are witnesses we know this so here's the
thing
I know social media thinks she's gonna
like slap him in jail or something I
don't I don't see this happening I see
it gonna say hey watch it buddy watch it
pal watch your social media post or this
will happen that's generally what
happens in these but didn't didn't he
get a warning in the beginning well
right but their warning is when they
when they actually so when that's I'll
tell you from experience yeah and
actually arraign you they give you a
warning when they Reign you they're like
here's your conditions and if you break
them I will come down on you right now
every judge is different the judge can
do whatever she thinks is right in this
case which I think I actually trust this
judge not only is this judge a very
smart judge she was 95 to nothing in her
confirmation right and the other thing
that really impresses me with this judge
is how she's treated the January 6
defendants in their cases
um so I know she's going to be very um
she's gonna be very fair but she's going
to hold a very very heavy Hammer but the
other thing too is that she he was a
public defender so not only does she
understand like the CR the the
Department of Justice and the court
system side of it she understands the
defendant side of it as well right which
I actually think makes her a better
judge I just I actually I think that
she'll
in this one instance as a warning do you
think that because I think the biggest
thing that people are going to complain
about especially on the right are going
to say well if there is something yeah
that like a gag order like a gag order
if a gag order is even though he's you
know even though in previous other and
uh arraignments that he's had uh he's
responded in such an aggressive way
against Jack Smith
or uh eating Carol's lawyer or anyone
that has been in or you know um
anyone that has actually gone after
Trump in a court setting you know follow
the rule of law
he's been arraigned
and they say look
don't do anything too crazy
and then he does some crazy [__] where
he yeah I mean I mean he is Trump I mean
right I said last week when when they
actually arraigned him I'm like yeah
this or this this conditions he's gonna
break this in less than 24 hours there's
no way this guy can stop crying there's
no way I mean it was it was even it was
less than it was less than 24 hours or
exactly or whatever yeah oh it was it
was almost instantaneous the thing is is
this I I think now this is just my
prediction and again this is based on
the judge she doesn't go outside the
bounds of the law she she's she's very
fair but she carries a very you know
very heavy hammer and she's shown that
with all these January 6 defendants
so my my my prediction is is that she's
very heavy in in him and telling him hey
you cannot post about Witnesses or
evidence in this case on social media or
I am going to do this from here on out
you cannot post because he's being very
careful in how he says it too right the
statement was if you [__] with me I'll
[__] come get you that kind of [__]
yeah if you come for me I'm coming for
you right right right but it's so broad
it's so you know this is how Mobsters
talk it's like those are a nice set of
legs be ashamed if something happened to
him you know that sort of [__] yeah like
I'm not gonna break your legs but I'll
break your legs if you know what I mean
you know they happen to fall down those
stairs right I was never there right
exactly again so so that's the part
where I'm curious about is like
as as how political this whole thing is
in terms of the scope or like the lens
that it's portrayed through you know I
could I could see her even though
everyone's like oh man I hope she
[__] tears him up and she could
right in a rhetoric way or like uh like
why did she will yeah I think I think
she will in her statement in her and
reprimanding him I think she's gonna
make him look two inches tall right yeah
she's shown that in the other cases of
the January 6th defense
look at it I look at it as the same way
uh or I I see it as a way of
trying to be fair even though anyone
else in this instance would be like
you're okay you're done like you're
[__] done gag order or I'm gonna you
know I'm gonna hold you in contempt or
whatever it might be but in terms of how
the right will portray it and how the
right is going to push the narrative is
this is unfair this is an Obama judge
even though all Republicans voted for
her and 95 to zip yeah and even though
she had uh I think it's with the bar
they were like amazing right she's she's
a phenomenal judge judge Cannon was
Judge Cannon is I believe is like she's
[__] they're like she's [__] like I and
I'm paraphrasing here but I believe the
bar said about Eileen Cannon was like um
kind of a lawyer
I think their exact quote was Elena Haba
would make a better federal judge I
think that's what they said yeah I think
that's what they said yeah honestly I
think that was the exact which is pretty
it's pretty impressive when you've got
when you got people
that are Trump's lawyers who are the
dumbest I mean I don't I mean I'm
looking at this John Laro guy and I'm
like how oh my God they just keep
getting Dumber this guy's such a [__]
idiot well here's yeah how can they not
get Dumber but they do every time right
so when he goes hey hey we need we need
an extension until like Tuesday or
Thursday I think it might have been
um well and that's all the delay thing
because they're gonna take every every
single way they can delay they're going
to try that's that's like asking someone
you know can I get an extension on the
paper and then you post photos at a
party
the night before right and that's
exactly what happened here he was like
hey we need an extension and then it
goes full Ginsburg and goes on all the
[__] Orange shows well I mean you
know I mean and it doesn't it doesn't
help that the Trump campaign sent out a
press release and they're like in case
anyone was curious our judge our
attorney John lauro is gonna go on all
the Sunday morning shows it's like dude
don't brag about it if you're trying to
get an extension because you don't have
enough time to repair then maybe you
should go prepare yeah maybe go prepare
and not try to advertise it to everyone
and brag that your lawyer is going on
all of these shows again my my my
um instinct is is this is Trump actually
testing this judge he tested the
Manhattan DA's office if you remember
like he went right up to the brink
remember the ball bat thing and all that
[__] and and what happened was is
basically the court told him hey either
[__] stop or we're gonna do something
and he's left he's left the Manhattan
D.A pretty much alone at this point you
know he hasn't done that he's testing
this judge he's not going to test Canon
because Canon's on his side I mean this
morning she's releasing an order in
motion or a statement basically telling
him hey you should what Trump should
probably do is is try to go for a
dimensional in this case because the
grand juries in DC not in Florida wink
like yeah actually coming coming from
the same woman who uh who who screwed it
up the first time right well she doesn't
know the law that's the problem she
didn't swear in right the the grand jury
which basically would you know almost
invalidated the whole thing well again
again she's she is not a uh she is not a
good actor she's not acting in good
faith yeah um but Jack Smith doesn't
have a choice here and that's you know I
text you on the weekend I said please
talk me out of attacking anyone who
talks about televising the DC trial
please talk about this but I couldn't be
talked out of it you you didn't reply so
I went out I was I went after them yeah
I went after them this morning on this
issue because it sounds it sounds like
they it sounds like Republicans are
taunting or did taunt to televise it and
the Democrats are like okay fine well I
I mean that may be true but the fact
remains at 9 1946 rule 53 was passed and
cameras and broadcasting is not allowed
in the federal court and this judge in
particular this judge is not going to go
outside the bounds of the rules of the
law she's just not going to do it she's
not going to do that Canon might but
this judge is not going to do that yeah
now our best chance our best chance for
a televised trial before the election
because that's the other thing that
really pisses me off about the campaign
for televised trial the thing that
pissed me off about is we're wasting our
energy on a trial that we don't even
know yet like there's not even a trial
yet and you're already talking about
televising it when we could be
politicizing so many other issues when
we could be wasting our breath and our
our campaigning and our energy on other
things but here's the thing is that if
you're looking for a televised trial in
Fulton County boy that's the place to do
it funny well it's not [__] around
even the sheriff down there releasing a
statement saying I'm gonna fingerprint
him and [__] mug shot him just like
every other sumbitch that comes in here
he's not going to be treated any
different I don't give a [__] who he is
which is only assigned in an indication
number one that he is going to be
indicted why did the why would the
sheriff say you goddamn right I'm going
to book him yeah if he wasn't planning
on doing that and he probably knows
Bonnie Willis is probably given the
Sheriff's Office a heads up like hey you
need to prepare to bring in a former
president and book his ass right
um so the sheriff has already indicated
that and by saying that you're also
indicating and sending the signal to
Trump hey you better not [__] around you
will find out in Fulton County because I
think the state can move to a a faster
trial possibly we'll see how many
defendants are in that trial and the
other thing too about it is hey guess
what what is what you can do in
courtrooms down in Georgia guess what
you can have in those courtrooms you can
televise them you can televise the [__]
out of it I'm just saying if you're
looking for a [__] reality show with
Trump at the at the at the ass end of
the the legal Hammer that's where to
have it I would I would I would love to
see
um I would honestly love to see the
people who complained like oh this is
costing us so much money and this is
such a big deal and this is such a
political weaponization of the
government and all this all this [__]
[__] we'll privatize it all right we'll
sell you the footage and tickets to
watch this thing and then we could
balance the [__] budget and then and
then I I bet we can pay off the national
debt and then we pay off any any of the
world the world would pitch in the world
would pitch in there everyone would buy
a [__] deal no longer would we have
to say hey China go buy these bombs from
us we'd say hey if you want you know
tickets buy a ticket five dollars every
day this goes on pay-per-view [__] it's
the best but I I could honestly see it
as a way for the state of Georgia to be
like look we're we're incurring all of
these all these expenses to have law
enforcement and you know extra guards
and security and you know people on
staff and and all of these things to say
like look
we'll just sell the tickets we'll pay
back we'll we'll make sure that the
budget in Fulton County and the
surrounding law enforcement areas are
compensated by selling pay-per-view
tickets could be yeah well and again if
you want to televise trial Manhattan and
Georgia the places do it because that's
where the courtrooms are that will allow
cameras and and someone said earlier in
the um in the chat uh
hedge said that that you know we should
repeal the law and and yeah certainly we
should probably have more transparently
transparency in federal courts but what
you have to understand about the rule 53
is it's also placed by federal judges so
this isn't like some sort of [__]
weird thing I mean we can legislate it
but if you expect Republicans in the
house to all of a sudden you know come
have a come to Jesus moment and decide
that they're gonna
you know televise a federal criminal
trial what that isn't even set yet it's
kind of weird I don't know it's just a
weird campaign I think it's feckless
it's ridiculous it's not it's not in our
interest to engage in it we can engage
in so many different activities right
now to to beat Donald Trump
um just like they beat the [__] out of
those white people on the dock in
Montgomery Alabama did you see that have
you been watching this video oh you're
watching this one I love it dude they
beat the [__] out of there dude okay so
yeah try that in a small town [__]
right that's exactly right so here's
here's the thing so uh I've watched a
lot of videos of the fighting and a lot
of memes of the fighting and they're all
funny as [__]
but the Avengers one's pretty good yeah
it is good it is good and then the
chairs oh my God all the chair memes the
folding chair memes
um so anyways
so the video that I watched that I was
convinced that
you know this is [__] ridiculous it
ain't no wonder everyone came to the aid
of this black security guard the reason
why if you watch the video leading up to
where they attacked him he's just trying
to get them to [__] move their butt
it's all he's trying to do he's like we
can't dock you have to he's and he's
pointing to on the dock I'm sure it's
written there that says fairy parking do
not park like it clearly probably says
you cannot park here on this dock this
is reserved it's probably bought space
that's why he's a security guard
standing there to make sure their space
is not taken up because there's there's
dozens and dozens of people on this
ferry that have to get off the ferry
that's the whole point and they need it
next to the handicap ramp obviously
because some people need the ramp and I
don't think these privileged white folk
which you know they probably don't
understand much other than their own you
know unique privilege that they have but
they thought it was their privilege to
park there and not only that when he
told them to move their [__] and he has
the authority to tell them to move their
[__] they beat they started to beat the
hell out of him yeah
um doesn't doesn't look look you can
look at this this footage
in any different way you won and of
course they're gonna people be like oh
my God look at this black on white crime
it's like no no let's watch the full
clip let's show exactly what happened
well here let me let me show you so here
so I'm not I'm not gonna play this sound
but yeah um I'm gonna play it as we talk
here so you can see the security guard
telling this guy to move and he looks
like he's agreeing but they're they're
really not there's another guy shirtless
guy is a wife there's another guy in the
red shorts here that's you know they
came up and yelled at him because he was
trying to get him to move the boat you
can see the boat has a cover on it so
not only do they Park they put their
cover on the boat so he's trying to get
him to move and they're mouthing they
don't want him and he's mouthing get
move your [__] [__]
um you can see this gentleman here in
the lipist it looks like he works for
the fairy
um he's in a shirt I think he's part of
the crew on the ferry yeah um and the
ferry is over you can see this is being
filmed from the ferry I think actually
someone jumped off the fair and swam
over uh there's another there's another
clip where the guy you just see a random
guy jumping and then swim to the dock to
beat the [__] out of these people
because they attacked the security guard
now if you if you're not if if you're on
the right wing they're really pissed off
about this like they're like oh my God
but if you watch this video here while
we're talking you'll see who threw first
punches you're gonna see it I mean it's
clear as day yeah and not only that you
can't park there you go park over there
right not only here you can't we gotta
park over there right not only that not
only that the security guard once he
gets assaulted he defends himself and
once he starts defending himself that's
when they all jump in and really attack
him and I believe I believe it's this
guy here I can't remember which one it
is I think this now here's another
gentleman who comes down it doesn't seem
to be anywhere near but he's trying he's
trying to uh make make the black guy
understand the white privilege that
these people have and he's like look I
don't give a [__] who you are this is
not your parking this is paid parking
for the ferry the ferry has to dock here
here so the people on the ferry can get
off the fairing go up the ramp I don't
give a [__] who you are what you think
you are move your [__] [__] you'll be
towed and and that's what he should have
been done there it is there it is the
first move let me back it up you see
he's talking to this guy here this guy's
trying to make the case of why these
people have white privilege it looks
like it appears that way
and he's trying to tell him hey man he
can't park there damn it that's I um
it's my job you can see the what they're
doing and then here he comes assaults
him now now the security guard is ready
to defend himself
he's like all right [__] it
um at that point at that point you know
you can see this guy's trying to break
it up this bystander but then they're
there they come in and just start just
start beating the hell out of him a
bunch of shirtless white guys and then
they start hitting the crew member you
see that yep they start hitting the crew
member
um and then out here you go now you've
had it there's all kinds of people
running down here to [__] with the the
guy on the blue shark the blue shirt
came from up top because there's another
footage where you see him he's oh [__]
and he runs down right and it was at
that moment when somebody jumps off the
the boat yeah jumps into the water to
swim around and I think the the people
the nickname that people gave him was uh
black woman black woman yeah
oh my God can you can you find The
Avengers meme uh the the the the one
with the Rings is that the one you're
talking about yeah finally that I mean
uh we'll show that here and then you've
got a what was that that we want to play
too which what was that uh
this one I did uh before
when I when I left so this this came out
on uh margin Taylor green one no no no
no this is the one that's on uh is that
what the one I sent you that's the one
on Trump this is okay okay good good
this is him spiraling after after good
good perfect so so we'll so we'll uh
we'll play that but I want to show you
in this Meme and then I want to talk
about uh Ohio for a second because
apparently Carrie lake is in Ohio and
the Republicans all of a sudden are
changing polling locations so if you're
in Ohio and you're wanting to vote and
you haven't voted yet uh tomorrow is the
day to vote no on one
um but what you need to do is you need
to check your polling locations because
there's there is
nefarious forces at foot here of course
it is Republicans who control
um a lot of Ohio and some of those polls
so they're changing locations see
there's a number you want to call
and I'm going to show that to you I'm
going to get you that number if you're
in Ohio or if you know someone Ohio
that's going to be voting you're going
to want to make sure to get them this
information so if you are in Ohio or you
know someone in Ohio you need to listen
up and get this information to them
because it's going to be very important
tomorrow
um uh when when we when the polls open
tomorrow because a lot of polling
locations have changed so I'm going to
show you that information but here's
meme
um now this is this is moments after the
the last moment that we saw where where
the scuffling really this is they had
gone down to the boat they fought at the
boat they came back up and then all of a
sudden this group uh black guys came out
right but the way in which this graphic
is done well if you've ever seen uh
Avengers it's end game then you'll know
the reference or you know or Doctor
Strange here is here is the um
what what are they calling these guys
um are they calling the Avengers no no
no they're gone no no the black guys are
these that's what I'm saying that's what
I'm saying yeah yeah yeah but you said
they're calling you're saying you're
calling the one guy you swam off the
boat there was another the guy who
jumped black woman black woman that's a
DC character yeah the blue Avengers and
I don't know I don't know
this is great Avengers Assemble and this
is a real photo They just added the
Rings that's all they added they didn't
do anything else but add the Rings and
this picture that's why it's so
hilarious because this is the this is
one of the best uh images from the the
Montgomery brawl as it's going to be
called well I think it I think they
named it the Alabama boat brawl is it
the Alabama broke ball I I was gonna
call it I was gonna call it the uh um
what was that have you seen have you
seen the church or have you seen the
chair memes that have come out oh [__]
yeah there's all kinds of chair means
they're fantastic and if you're not
you're not paying attention to the chair
means you need to get you need to go get
on black Twitter like now like right now
and and look at these memes they're
[__] I mean I saw some last night on
Tick Tock it was like here's uh
and there was this dude in the backyard
just practicing right right it's a video
of him this guy's carrying a chair on
his hip he's he's packed he's packing a
chair this might be this might be my
favorite one that I saw this morning of
how quickly people were on it right now
this was again this is
um this is an event that happened on
Saturday right does this happen on
Saturday yeah Saturday I think because
when I when I got
when I landed last night
yeah Saturday because it happened on the
yeah yeah this motherfucker's already
got a t-shirt
he's already got a t-shirt and this is
one of the moments right this is the
iconic this is the right WWE chair down
boom I mean this one guy he kept getting
up he got hit with the chair right fell
down you watched a video of this other
woman who like tries to jump in there
she just gets pushed down you see this
guy get hit with the chair it's Madness
it is hilarious to watch because in this
one moment I'm like yeah you all [__]
deserve that 100 no question about it
you [__] around and now you found out
all right and this guy says on his tweet
he says on my way to Cracker Barrel to
celebrate August 5th
2023 Jesus Christ he's already got a
[__] shirt made
people are quick man and I love it
that's the beauty of the internet
are you talking about you talk about
memes they are fast quick and in a hurry
to him uh so if you haven't if you
haven't watched they're calling it the
Alabama boat brawl if you type that in
on Twitter or any other social media
you'll probably see all the videos okay
last one last one oh okay all right here
we go we gotta go for one more
which one is uh let's see which one is
this one I I've seen is this a chair one
or is this okay this is a chair
oh Nathaniel Alexander he invented the
folding chair
uh is this real on on July 7th 1911
Nathaniel Alexander patented a folding
chair he designed his chair to be used
in schools churches and other
auditoriums apparently on boat docks too
apparently yeah this is this is true
this is a this is a this is a Black
History Month fact about the inventor of
the folding chair and his design
included a book rest
for the person sitting behind on a deal
for a church or choir use pretty sure
you'd find it the same as like in school
and whatnot when you're in yeah and when
you're in a boat brawl in Montgomery
Alabama you gotta have a place to put
your book for sure I mean these are
things that you have to have I mean just
anyway the WWE wrestling memes I've seen
out of this thing are oh yeah um amazing
amazing you can't you can't make this
[__] up because it it really happened it
didn't happen that way and I don't know
what to tell you yeah um so there's the
there's the Ally I Think I think if you
if you had that one chick from Waffle
House who who caught the chair with one
yeah and [__] threw it back or
whatever that one plus these guys oh my
God undefeated I think I think there's a
bunch of memes with uh John Cena in the
in the Waffle House throwing it yeah I
believe and then she's like throwing it
back right
um it's got the same energy doesn't it
it's got the same energy all right let's
go to welcome to let's go to um
what was that what was that so let's do
let's to Gabe Sanchez is what was that
on the Trump indictments here so without
further Ado what was that with uh Gaby
Gaby Gaby Sanchez we're glad you're back
my friend let's listen to what was that
welcome to what was that I'm Gabe
Sanchez Donald Trump has officially been
indicted three times and Republicans are
losing their [__] over it what a day huh
what a day to be alive but before we get
into that make sure to like this video
subscribe to this Channel and ring that
notification Bell so you never miss
another video it really seems like the
courtroom doors just can't get enough of
Donald Trump this year I mean the guys
collecting indictments like some people
collect Pokemon cards gotta indict them
all now if my math is correct Donald
Trump was charged with 34 felony counts
and the falsification of business
records case 40 counts and the
mishandling of classified documents case
and now he's been charged with four
felony counts in the 2020 election
interference case which means across
three separate cases in this year alone
Donald Trump has racked up 78 felony
counts that's pretty much one count for
every year he's been alive and per usual
the the only reason that we knew about
the incoming indictment was because
Trump ran a true Social Wine about it if
anything he's at least consistent about
giving everyone a heads up the
indictment in question came with four
charges with conspiring to defraud the
United States
conspiring to disenfranchise voters
and conspiring and attempting to
obstruct an official proceeding
the indictment was issued by a Grandeur
of citizens here in the District of
Columbia
and it sets forth the crimes charged in
detail in the first two census and this
indictment are a knockout punch the
defendant Donald J Trump was the 45th
president of the United States and a
candidate for re-election in 2020. the
defendant lost the 2020 presidential
election
the indictment also lists six unnamed
co-conspirators and Trump's starting
coup lineup we are prepared to identify
five of them at this point based on
reporting from our CNN team I think most
notably the first unindicted
co-conspirator who again is unnamed in
this indictment we have identified as
Rudy Giuliani the indictment notes that
this is someone who called the Arizona
speaker of the house that was Rusty
Bowers somebody who made a presentation
before Georgia State lawmakers and the
person that Donald Trump tapped to lead
his post-election legal efforts that is
all Rudy Giuliani number two in this
indictment is former Trump Attorney John
Eastman this is a person who wrote this
two-page memo this was the plan for from
Mike Pence to be able to essentially
overturn the 2020 presidential election
while presiding over the Electoral
College certification number three on
this list another former Trump attorney
Sidney Powell they point out that she
filed a lawsuit against the governor of
Georgia which we knew they also point
out in this indictment that Donald Trump
was espousing the theories of this
co-conspirator even though he had
privately admitted that they sounded
crazy we know all of that to be Sydney
Powell co-conspirator number four on
this list is someone we've talked about
a lot former justice department official
Jeffrey Clark the indictment identifies
him as a justice justice department
official it also points to an email that
a top doj a person sent to Clark
rebutting his efforts to try to use the
department to overturn the 2020 election
and again number five we have a pro
another pro-trump lawyer this is Kenneth
chesbrough he was someone who was very
involved in this fake electors plot the
indictment points to an email memorandum
that he sent to Giuliani on in December
of 2020 about the fake electors plot
good co-conspirator 6B Michael Flynn
Jenny Thomas Roger Stone Tom fit and
Steve Bannon or maybe just someone else
until we find out I feel like we're
playing a game of guess who Insurrection
Edition is it me is it you no yes
oh and after it was revealed that Rudy
Giuliani is Trump's co-conspirator one
in the indictment he was ranting and
raving on Newsmax so here's what I say
to Jack Smith after the Supreme Court
threw out your case
should should have been a disgrace and
you should have gone and found another
profession because you don't belong in
this one
this one will be your legacy
violating
the right of free speech of an American
citizen never mind whether he was
present or not
it could be anybody it could be a
homeless person
you don't get to violate people's first
amendments right Smith no matter who the
hell you are or no matter how sick you
are with Trump derangement syndrome
and this isn't the first time you've
acted like an unethical lawyer it should
be the last
these morons were so hungry for power
that they would do whatever they could
to keep it and guess what it cost them
everything so let's all make sure to
officially welcome these
insurrectionists to the find out phase
of their attempted coup the more you
[__] around
the more you're going to find out and
here's the truth they have absolutely no
chance against special counsel Jack
Smith I mean the guy eats nails for
breakfast and investigated International
crimes at the Hague and of course as
soon as the new indictment from Jack
Smith became public Donald Trump
released a deranged statement now I'm
not going to bore you with this nonsense
and whining but there was one part that
I do want to highlight the lawlessness
of these persecutions of President Trump
and his supporters is reminiscent of
Nazi Germany in the 1930s the former
Soviet Union and other authoritarian
dictatorial regimes all right not only
is that statement incredibly offensive
but as you can see Trump is definitely
not freaking out at all and totally
taking this well and by well I mean not
at all even Donald Trump's future
ex-wife Carrie Lake had something to say
his poll numbers will continue to go up
I really believe that those other people
running in the Republican race should
stand up speak out and support of
President Trump talk about how this is
an injust Justice like we've ever seen
with our department of justice going
after an innocent man and frankly they
should suspend their campaigns and step
behind and support president Trump and
the American people so we can save this
great country Don Jr was on Newsmax too
discuss his father's indictment which I
imagine was his attempt to connect with
his father I just wanted to ask if
you've talked to your father and uh his
how's he feeling
yeah actually I spoke to him a little
bit ago and he's doing great no Donald
Trump is definitely not doing great and
if I had to guess the walls at
Mar-A-Lago are probably dripping with
ketchup like it's a scene from The
Shining one of the the charges uh that
they allege here is that your father
knew uh that this was all bogus and he
pushed it anyway do you buy that
buy anything uh that they're putting out
there these days Rob I mean have we
noticed the pattern of what's Happening
have we seen what they're doing on a
daily basis I mean what my father's
right why did they wait two and a half
years you know why because he's leading
in the polls because they're afraid of
him becoming president and dismantling
the uni party dismantling the Deep State
I don't believe in this level of
coincidence anymore if you look at the
fact pattern literally the day day after
Hunter Biden's BFF testifies
was involved in all of these schemes he
was on the phone 20 plus times they
indict Trump Don Jr can whine all he
wants about Joe Biden but there is one
thing that we know for certain President
Joe Biden has zero felony counts and
Donald Trump well he currently has 78
and Counting oh and when it comes to the
Smoking Gun known as Hunter Biden's
former business associate Devin Archer
Republicans had to have a non-televised
session because they knew they had
nothing don't take my word for it just
listen to representative Andy Biggs
you didn't know anything about that
but even though Republicans have no
evidence against Joe Biden that hasn't
stopped them from painting Trump as the
victim Benny Johnson tweeted did you
notice that the Biden Administration
waited to drop the new Trump indictment
until the exact moment that republicans
in Congress fully exposed abiding crime
scheme they don't care about America
they don't care about the truth they
don't care about Trump all they care
about is holding on to power well that's
funny considering that Trump was
literally the guy trying to do
everything he could to stop fighting
from becoming presidents after Biden won
the election with 81 million votes and
look it's simple if Republicans actually
have proof on the bidens like they claim
then just show it already stop claiming
that whistleblowers and informants are
going missing just show us the damn
evidence you know what here's a
suggestion go ask Jim Jordan and James
Comer to release the transcripts from
the session with Devin Archer oh that's
right they won't because they know it'll
prove that they can actually back up
their bribery accusation so instead
Republicans have to distracting claim
that it's a political Witch Hunt or even
a civil war like Tim the full pool so
eloquently tweeted which I find Rich
coming from the guy who used this
platform to get people to show up on
January 6th the very Insurrection that
spurred this whole investigation into
Donald Trump and now Donald Trump is
calling on his supporters to descend on
Washington D.C January 6th this could be
Trump's Last Stand and it's a time when
he has specifically called on his
supporters to arrive in D.C that's
something that may actually be the big
push Trump supporters need to say this
is it it's now or never on that day
Trump says show up for a protest it's
gonna be wild and based on what we've
already seen from the previous events I
think Trump is absolutely correct but
it's not just right-wing idiots like Don
Jr Benny Johnson or Tim Poole that are
losing their minds over this it's also
Fox News just take a look at Jesse
Waters going ballistic over Trump's
indictment we also have January 6 and I
feel comfortable speaking for Jessica
you really shouldn't
speak for the rest of the country that
has their head on straight not everybody
believes January 6th was Hiroshima not
everybody believes that no one we talk
to people on the street all the time a
lot of people don't even know what
January 6 was and for the people that
watch it on TV they're over it they
don't see it as a holy day the way you
guys do again the documents case and I'm
talking about what Biden did with it
what Trump did with it regular Americans
on Main Street aren't fussing over where
the documents went they really don't
care it doesn't affect them in the 90s
you had sex it was titillating people
were very focused on it it was a
different culture back then okay if you
find cash bribes that go into Biden's
offshore bank accounts that's going to
light up the country that is a cash
bribe from a foreign company that's in
the bank account
goodbye okay sex and cash bribes that's
gonna do it documents and January 6th
it's not going to do it you have another
thing Greg said it this is like
lawfare they call it legal Warfare if
this was political this would be like a
political war crime this is overkill
this is political germ warfare these are
political war crimes it's an atrocity
it's like not just dropping one atomic
bomb you drop 15 dozen Jessica enough is
enough this is the establishment
terrified of Donald Trump's re-election
because of all the money that's going to
dry up and all the influence and you
know what they're terrified of the
payback and that's what this is about
and what happens if you trigger a
re-election by Donald Trump and he gets
in there you think he's not going to go
after the bidens he might go after Dr
Jill at this point after you've been
rummaging through melania's underwear
drawer turning his life upside down
payback is going to be a you know what
and you guys started it his gaslighting
is very reminiscent of when he recently
tried to spend Florida's black history
curriculum as a good thing no one is
arguing slaves benefited from slavery no
one is saying that it's not true
they're teaching how black people
develop skills during slavery in some
instances that could be applied for
their own personal benefit so as the
2020 election interference case develops
you can fully expect more tantrums and
freakouts from Republican lawmakers as
well as right-wing commentators as they
try to Grapple with the fact that Trump
might be done because if there is one
thing for certain it's that Donald Trump
is definitely not doing great well
that's all for me today thanks so much
for watching and feel free to connect
with me on Instagram threads YouTube or
Twitter at I am Gabe Sanchez and if you
want to be a part of what makes my show
possible plus get access to episodes
before they go public plus a bonus show
on the weekend you can do so by going to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez
game Sanchez is back welcome back
welcome back welcome back glad to have
you back my friend and glad that you did
the um the what was that that's great
that was a great one you're muted hang
on and you gotta unmute yourself there
we go yeah uh yeah that was that was a
fun one I gotta I got another one I got
like three planned I got one on
uh Greg Gutfeld
I got one that I'm working on today
which is
um John lauro lauro the guy who that we
were talking about is Trump's attorney
he did the new ridiculous attorney new
guy who just did the full Ginsburg and
the [__] that he says yesterday on
Sunday
is insane uh dumber than Elena Haba and
Trump combined somehow it's possible I'm
going to be doing it what was that
that's the next one to come out and then
uh I've also got one on a mother out of
Houston who [__] demolishes the
superintendent Mike miles oh yes yes I I
watched part of that that video and it's
it's it's a beautiful beautiful moment
where she's like I got your number I'm
about to be your best friend
your wife and your kids son Alabama boat
brawl style [__]
I wonder if anyone's buying the uh stock
and bowling chairs all around I don't
know that's a good question try that in
a small town [__]
so yeah I got four I got three three on
the way uh this week so please if you
like what you see and like what you just
saw right now make sure to go check it
out at patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez or
you can go to what was thatshow.com and
you can get little extras tonight uh
because I was traveling yesterday and I
had a delayed flight tonight we'll be
doing the weekend Roundup so if you're
not if you're not a part of the patreon
make sure to sign up so that you can
watch it tonight and I'll go over all
the things I'll be talking about in the
upcoming what was that and as well as
anything else you guys want to talk
about it's a fun time to come join I I
made sure to tell all the patreon
members that I had in my uh patreon
meeting last night the Sunday rant that
because Joy Leaf I think brought it up
that you were gonna do it tonight so I
announced it to them so hopefully
everyone yeah yeah so please sign up
because you know it's gonna be it's
gonna it's gonna be wild it's gonna be
wild you know I think the piece of news
that I got out of this what was that is
I I think the breaking news that I got
out of this is that uh Carey lake is his
uh future ex-wife okay okay the people
people say that might be my funniest
joke yet it was it was a good one the
people that have watched this and
commented that seems to be uh there's
well the The Guess Who game that was a
good one I was cracking up when that one
and then also uh the future ex-wife joke
that I made everyone seems to be like
that like the future ex-wife funniest
thing I mean if people comment and like
I watched this video and I'm still
laughing they killed it killed and well
the comments were lighting up when it
happened too when we were playing them
yeah down here so hey if you guys like
what you see please support me check out
the patreon
go to patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez Gabe
did you hear that oh Ohio Republicans
are sleazy can you imagine no
Republicans yeah they sure are they're
trying they're trying to move the goal
post out there a higher uh Republicans
are so damn Shady hashtag no on issue
one Chris for Webb points this out um
it's an important Ohio alert and I think
it's uh good that we show it here on the
show and there's a telephone number that
you can call as well here
um and it's in certain counties you need
to double check your polling location
but I would go and venture to say that
no matter where you're at in Ohio you
should check your polling location if
you plan on voting tomorrow which you
should if you have not already go and
voting no on one you need to you need to
double check your polling location
there's a number you can call here
um Chris says this stinks to high heaven
at the last minute before Ohio's special
election polling locations were changed
more than 47 000 voters are affected by
changes to 50 voting precincts now
election day is tomorrow and the polls
are open from 6 30 a.m to 7 30 p.m
respectively in their time zone and you
can call and what you need to do I think
this is what you need to do and this is
a red alert that he's issuing Fox 8 had
the story and here's the number you can
call the county election board
has sent notification lenders to the
effective voters but you need to confirm
and I would urge you if you or someone
you know is in Ohio they should call to
check their their polling location the
numbers right here it's
216-443-8683 that's
216-443-8683 that's 216-443 vote
um if you're wanting the numeric or
excuse me the alphabetic number there
two one six four four three eight six
eight three call and check your polling
location to make sure if it has changed
you know exactly where you need to vote
tomorrow
August 8th 2023 from 6 30 a.m to 7 30
p.m so uh Chris thank you for bringing
this to everyone's attention uh and
thank you for the work you do on Twitter
and getting us this information is very
important uh that we do this and we and
again folks this is what I'm saying
about spending our energy on certain
things like there's certain things we
can spend our energy on something
probably is not going to happen like the
cameras in a courtroom of a trial that
isn't even scheduled
it's not something we need to be
spending our energy on right now there's
a lot more things that are more
important than that little single thing
that you want I want it to everyone
wants it even Trump wants it to be quite
honest he wants it but the thing is is
that what we need to do is focus our
energy on on beating back fascism with
the ballot and that is most important so
I want to thank Christopher Webb for
bringing that to to our attention and
giving the folks the resources they need
to call and check their polling location
again you can call
216-443-8683 if you're in Ohio or pass
along that number to a voter in Ohio if
they're unsure about their polling
location that is how they confirm their
their voting location and where it will
be to make sure they can cast their
ballot tomorrow in Ohio's special
election and vote no on issue one
um so there you go there's my um
democracy PSA I guess you call it right
I don't know I don't know well speaking
of that
um so this week we got some special
gifts We got Jess Piper coming on on
Wednesday we're gonna try to do a
workshop with Jess Piper on on patreon
the the Roundtable democracy you guys
have seen some of these videos they're
free to watch on a playlist you can go
to Roundtable of democracy.com and you
can it'll take you directly to the
playlist but um tomorrow I think I'm
gonna do a website and Gabe if you want
to join you come join we're gonna do a
tour I'm going to tour everyone on moms
of actions website okay the other one
that everyone's because because they're
highly engaged uh in gun safety and a
lot of people want to be engaged in that
realm engaging your democracy there is
perfect if if that's what you feel
comfortable with but also in moms of
action is a great organization it's ran
by Shannon Watson and she she's such a
great activist when it comes to gun
control she's all over it she's so smart
maybe we'll have her on the show soon to
talk about it maybe we'll get her to do
a workshop or some some of her some of
her great staff and other activists at
moms of action to do work jobs with us
on how to engage with moms of Mom's
demands action but the other one is
field team six so we did a workshop on
um fivecalls.org and I'm gonna get neon
I think he's gonna be on next month to
to be on the show and then do a workshop
on that website to do specific things
about it take specific questions about
the website but the other one people are
talking about are field team six because
it's like five calls but it's texting so
it's like texting you're representing
text so so I'm gonna I think maybe
tomorrow we'll do the moms of action uh
we'll see if Jess Piper can do a um if
Jess Piper can do a workshop this week
she's going to be a guest on Wednesday
and uh maybe we'll I'll do a workshop on
field team six where we just tour the
website we kind of look at it try to
figure it out together of what what this
resource is we did a great one with
Mighty librarian last week on a state by
state election website resource that she
put together is really cool like if you
whatever state you need to know election
laws in you just click the website and
Bam you're right there there's no trying
to search for it or trying to find it
she put it in a nice organized fashion
so it's easy to find it's easy to
reference
um and that video is right now on the
playlist along with the finecalls.org
where we phone a bonehead so today if
you're thinking about phoning boneheads
you probably you probably should phone a
bonehead is what you should probably do
Tommy tuberville is a good one always
always
but the other guest that we're going to
have on soon is Fred Wellman uh we're
gonna try to get him on this week he
really he's really making a big push you
know that uh Fred's a veteran and and
he's making a big push
um he had the the the press secretary on
for the VA and he at Terence Hayes and
he's talking about The Pact act and how
to file for the benefits and it's by
August 9th so
um make sure make sure that you you get
this filed and we get this out there
again this is another great way to
engage in your democracy and get this
get this out there so maybe we'll have
Jess and Fred on Wednesday oh and
Thursday we have a special guest yes
we've got uh Reagan who's an employee at
weiner Circle the wiener Circle in
Chicago and so she's gonna come on and
she's going to talk about Ed Sheeran All
of the activism they do the wonderful
signs they make and did you see some of
the did you see some of the chair memes
they've been doing I haven't seen it yet
oh yeah well there's a big feud between
them and Portillo's right so yeah I have
seen the updated ones on them so yeah
what to ask we'll have to ask her about
those yeah
we'll have her on on Thursday tell
everyone what Weiner's circle is so they
know okay let me see if I can pull up
something the wiener circle is a hot dog
spot in Chicago
it's known for many many things but one
of them is just the amount of trash
talking and roasting that happens inside
it's a late night spot they go into and
it's just absolute chaos but
it's a lot of fun you got people who are
taking the orders it's it's just like
insults on crack uh uh on like just just
amped up entirely
going in there's also you know you order
a milkshake or chocolate milkshake is I
don't know if they still do it they did
it years ago uh it's definitely where
people
lift up their shirt and they show their
tits and they fling around whoa whoa
whoa whoa hey yeah you're getting you're
gonna get the audience so excited anyway
so wait is that zero days that we have
to talk about porn dead zero days now
okay yeah I just want to make sure we
get the counter correct or big stuff
over on uh yeah
uh they've got a ton it's a ton of fun
um I mean last time I was in Chicago I
went there with friends it's just
non-stop just like back and forth it's
just like you go in there knowing you're
gonna get roasted and that's kind of fun
and you go in there to get a hot dog as
well right anyway exactly and they're
great they're great hot dogs I hear I
hear they're great hot dogs so here's
what we should do because me and you
have talked about the audience some know
some don't know we've never actually met
in person we've never never actually
been in person it's you know
unfortunately for him honestly that he
hasn't met me in person
but here's the thing if if we end up
going because we talked about going to
the Democratic National Convention next
summer yeah yeah maybe maybe we'll cause
some trouble there yeah yeah and maybe
maybe we'll go maybe we'll go to wieners
Circle we'll see if we can go and have
have a have a dog
um and we sure and the question I have
to ask is is uh well two questions
ketchup or and is hot dog a sandwich you
know I mean we can ask those questions
I'll say it right now no ketchup no
ketchup if you're doing a Chicago dog no
ketchup yeah and then also is a hot dog
a sandwich no it's not a [__]
sandwich a hot dog is a hot dog it's its
own thing it is I asked Mark I asked
Mark Cuban that question on threads he
came on threads and he said ask me
anything and I asked him if hot dog was
the sandwich he said it was yeah what he
said and I said and I think my response
was something along the lines of you
never go to like a basketball game or a
baseball game and say yeah let me get a
sandwich and a beer right no one ever
says I'm not a sandwich in a beer it's a
hot dog in a beer in and of itself here
here's here's that Meme I was talking
about oh yeah yeah so here's here's the
wiener search figuratively speaking and
um
hahaha
Portillo's is a hot dog stand yeah
Portillo's is another hot dog place uh
they've got a ton they've actually got
one out here in uh uh in the LA area
south of where I am but they're in a
kind of a feud with yeah yeah and so
most of them most of them are in Chicago
area I used to go there as a kid
um as well so you know as a Chicago Kid
you you go to any spot that's got a hot
dog to to try out and see if it's good
if you want to go back or whatever but
yeah wiener circle is good
um tons of fun
and like I said it's not a sandwich
it's not a sandwich it's just like it's
just like Arnold Schwarzenegger would
say in Kindergarten Cop is not a
sandwich it's not a sandwich and let me
let me let me tell you if you want to
have some fun you gotta go to our
Discord I know you're on the Discord
have you been in there to see this chat
it is popped in I popped in on Friday
for like a brief moment and uh they're
like lighting it up over there yeah
they're just like well because yours is
public right yeah yeah okay okay mine is
in public mine it you get the Discord if
you sign up right you don't mind how do
I want to do yeah yeah right mine is
public you can go over there and do
whatever you want now we got mods over
there and we're gonna we're gonna do
some things to keep the Nazis at Bay
once they find out that thing exists
because once they find out exists
they're gonna hate that [__] but
you know what hey let them hate it I
don't care love me or love to hate me
that's how you want to do but if you
want to go if you're in the chat right
now and you like chat whether it's
YouTube Facebook or twitch this I'm
telling you I go in there every once
while just pop in and see what they're
talking about I might throw in a comment
or two but it is literally like the chat
24 7 in there because there are people
all around the world chat somebody just
somebody just pinged me in in did they
see yeah they said Gabe caretaker 909
question mark
now I'll give you I'll see there see
there you go see what I'm saying they're
I mean they're lining up let me let me
put the um let me put the link to the
Discord in the in the uh in the chat
here so you guys have it uh and that's
so like I so here's the thing so I have
one for my patreon right I think you
actually set up the one for the show uh
for me yeah yeah I had no I I had no
idea what the [__] so the question is
the question is do I open it up to
everyone I I mean I don't know I don't
know but I I Hey listen if you want it
because here's the thing we got we got
the lobby over there on Discord where
it's a 24-hour chat we have the live
show channel chat where you're like
chatting as the live show is going which
has been going I actually you know what
I think has been slowing down my
computer is dis I've had Discord up on
my computer uh and that's what's bogging
my [__] down because they're like
they're just posting so much [__] so I
took it down for the show and I'm gonna
bring it back up
so see if you want to get involved in
the chat if you like the chat here on
the show and you like the chat family on
the show I know you're going to love the
Discord because they're all over there
all the time you don't have to put down
the chat it's where the the party does
not stop over there it's where the chat
continues over there on the Discord so I
put that let me put it one more time in
the chat here so you guys have it and if
you don't have Discord or you're trying
to figure it out I'm trying to figure it
out too don't don't be you know
disappointed it's pretty easy when you
want to chat in a certain room
um so I I'm still trying to figure it
out too but to skip over there and we
got other moderators helping out in chat
to help because I'm I'm a Discord
um infant at this point but I'm getting
used to it I'm trying to get used to it
so and they also they also been
streaming our show and a bunch of other
shows and a bunch of other stuff in the
uh in the voice section so if you want
to watch some streaming stuff going on
they're streaming over there too all the
time and they're talking in voice chat
you can talk to each other I actually
went into the voice chat the other day
and and said a few things to some folks
over there that were in the voice chat
they were talking so go to the Discord
and I'm I I think it's really cool
I didn't know Discord you know was that
cool but you guys make it cool you guys
make everything cool just like you make
this show cool every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific right here on the
tubes of you do not forget to subscribe
here on YouTube hit the like button and
[__] if you dislike me hit the dislike
button too I don't care love me or love
to hate me sounds good to me as long as
you engage while you're here also you
can watch it on Facebook live every
single weekday at the Tony Michaels if
you still have a book so face account
you can also watch and follow us over on
Twitch it's always lighten up on Twitch
don't forget if you have an Amazon Prime
account linked to your Twitch account to
re-subscribe every single month at
twitch.tv slash the Tony Michaels and if
you have a Prime account and you haven't
linked your Prime account your Twitch
account no problem it's easy to do Gabe
Sanchez you just go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com you scroll down you hit the
link that says link Amazon on in Prime
and when you you get one free
subscription with your Amazon Prime
account and I know you do this every
month you link it to the Twitch account
and Amazon sends us like two dollars
every month and you get to subscribe for
free you get to get commercial free
watching on Twitch when you watch the
show live so there's no reason not to do
it and re-subscribe every single month
we had um someone just a couple hours
ago
um for the fifth month in a row the
fifth month in a row two months in a row
four months in a row uh so go make sure
to hit the re-subscribe on that also
download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify
Google you get a five finger discount
over there did you know that game it is
I did know that yeah 3.99 doesn't cost
you a single nickel also make sure to go
visit our patreon Pages Gabe's
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez check out
all the extras he's doing over there for
well he's got a weekend Roundup tonight
make sure to join it'll be fun get it
going and tomorrow I'm gonna do I think
we're gonna do the Mom's demand action
tomorrow the workshop on the website
tour sometime tomorrow afternoon so go
to patreon.com the Tony Michaels if you
want to participate in that live event
but don't fret I'll provide it for you
for free after we're done recording
it'll post up on YouTube so you'll be
able to see the workshop you'll be a CR
work that we do over on patreon with the
patreon group but if you want to join in
live check out patreon.com the Tony
Michaels until tomorrow you know this
same time same place
sir what's up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass speaking